With, we have a hierarchy of life,
things that are closest to us,
we feel more connected to.
We don't feel connected at all to bugs.
Nobody gives a fuck about right.
Vegan slap mosquitoes all day long.
Nobody gives a shit about that life.
But there is a life that you care
about when things get warm and
they get like too close to us. Yeah. When
they, when they get too close to mammal,
like people freak out.
Yeah.
I went on a South African safari
last year and it was like, ew,
I couldn't fathom someone going and
hunting a leopard or something like that.
That's a weird thing. That's a big
game. Shit. That's a very weird thing.
It's a very different thing.
It's not, it's not a, it's a,
it's almost like what that is.
And I'm not saying it shouldn't sadism,
maybe a little,
but what that is is like
it's an aberration off the
original idea and it is,
this is the only way to look at it.
And people would get mad at me that are
hunters cause I'm a hunter and like what
do you say?
Look,
it's not the thing to do unless
you're doing it on PR just to control
population. There's no
reason to do it, but what,
what happened was in the past,
the only reason people hunted was from me.
You barely could stay alive anyway,
and when you went on a hunting party,
he didn't go for sport.
You went to go to kill things.
When you have so much food that you
don't need to worry about food and you've
already been shooting all these animals,
then they start doing
these things called slams.
They called doing super
slams are the grand slam.
There's a dall sheep slam is a sheep slam,
a rocky,
like a big horn sheep slam. There's a
wise, like a Gymboree. No, no, no. You,
you try to kill one representative
of each of the subspecies. God,
really? Yeah. It's a big thing.
It's a big thing with these guys.
It's a poker run calm like the,
the,
the big six are the big eight in
Africa. Africa. It's a big five.
Is that what it is? The Big Five, the five
most dangerous animals to hunt on foot.
It's like Cheetah Lion,
hippo,
Rhino and that whatever the fuck leopard.
That brick. Yeah. There's a bunch of these
kind of slams. They haven't for Turkeys.
They have a wild Turkey slam.
You get the Gould's Turkey,
get the Osceola Turkey.
There's a bunch of different turkeys
all over the country. One in Florida.
There's one in Mexico.
It's different Turkey point being
people start collecting and it gets,
it gets weird. Well that's the
trophy, right? Yeah. It's weird.
It's like it gets to this weird place
like you don't think they shouldn't do it.
Like, okay, are you eating the
Turkey? You are. Okay, that's cool.
Are you eating the deer? Yup.
Okay, well then I have no quarrel,
but when you start going like lie in hose,
I said Cheetos. Elephant was
the other one. Yeah. Yeah man.
I mean the only reason why I shoot an
elephant is if the elephants going on a
rampage through her village telling
people and you want to protect people's
lives and I'm on team people.
Other than that,
why the fuck else would you
shoot an if I have no idea, like
I saw the elephant that
the biggest elephant I've
ever seen as far away from me as you
were sitting right now, my God and I all,
I almost had a heart attack yet.
Africa on a safari.
See,
but I think those things are amazing.
It was amazing. It was amazing. But like
you just know because what you're doing,
the reason I was so close is because we
were watching them push trees down with
their trunks,
like four or five inch trees just from,
Oh my God. Like it's nothing.
You know what I mean?
Like you'd crash a car
if you hit one of those,
it would crash the car and
like they're just phone,
phone and they're right next to you
and if they go thumb on your jeep,
that's the end of that.
You know what's complicated?
Someone was trying to explain this to
me and I should really be honest about
this. A guy was trying to explain
to me that when we think of Africa,
we think of a country,
it's not a country.
It's a continent and it's a way
bigger confidence in North America.
We've seen pictures of United States
stuck in the middle of Africa.
Africa is fucking huge.
And he's like,
unfortunately there's places in Africa
where they have over populations of
elephants and they encroach on human
civilization and they do have to hire
hunters to come in and do it and
kill him. Well, they don't hire him.
The hunters pay and the money
goes straight to the village.
The meat goes to a village and people
get very excited about people hunting
these elephants.
And when
probably seems like a sort of short term
solution to the village, right? They,
the village doesn't give a shit
about the elephants. They want their,
they want to eat,
eat
probably. Right. Well
they can eat their crops.
It becomes a big issue and they eat
the fuck out of there. You know,
like good luck.
They only got him LFO now given no chance.
So when someone was explaining
this to me, I remember, you know,
we were saying this,
I was like,
why the fuck would you ever
want to kill an elephant?
We know there's not that many
of them. And he's like, yeah,
this is why it's complicated.
There's not that many of them.
In some places it's like in
La there's no grizzly bears,
but if you go to Montana or the people
that live in Montana or go into, hey,
when are you going to start
hunting these fucking things?
They just declared them open for uh,
in Wyoming,
they're, they're not, they don't have,
they think they just started a hunting
season and it's very controversial and
they just end date. No, no, not anymore
at all. No. They have a lot of them.
And the people that live up there,
especially people that have been mauled
or know people that have been molded
like, hey, fucking
enough enough. I get it.
They made a great comeback. But
you know, if you're in Chicago,
the zero bears, so if, and this is a
tiny place in comparison to Africa.
So when I was saying that like,
I thought that elephants were endangered.
He's like,
yes and no.
There are endangered in some areas
and good point to fucked up point.
The most dark point about all of it is
that trophy hunting is the only thing
that keeps those animals healthy.
This is what's fucked up.
I was talking to my plane campaigns
about this this weekend when,
and this is what I say,
trophy hunting.
I'm even talking about normal hunting
meat like impalas or you know Elan's.
He's big. He's a big game animals that
people hunt for cause they're delicious.
Even them in Zimbabwe.
There's a lot of areas in
Zimbabwe that are not high fence.
They're just open enormous areas.
All of the money that would come from
people hunting there would sustain these
local areas,
sustain these lodges.
So it would make it viable to
keep these animals alive and stop.
Poachers responds the anti
poaching, right? Exactly.
The only thing that funds
the anti poaching. So here's
what happened. The Cecil,
the Lion Shit went down.
Nobody wanted to go to Africa anymore to
go hunting and all of these businesses
are going under,
so there's nothing stopping the poachers.
So the poachers move in and kill
everything, kill everything.
Thought that the other ways, how many
elephants were killed last year by people?
Something like 400 or Google
this legally killed elephants.
The number of illegally kill elephants,
30,000 come on.
30,000 most of them are killed illegally.
Most of them are poached.
They have this one elephant,
you know that last elephant that
was dying the mail or excuse me,
Briahna Reinstein White Rhino or black
rhino? We try. No, was it a black rhino?
I think they have that, that poor
bastard with armed guards around it.
24 seven because they were worried
someone's going to kill it,
shoot it and cop chop
the fucking horn off.
Like the poaching is way scarier than
the hunting and the only thing that
protects the animals
from poaching is hunting.
It sounds so on where to
live and so forth, but you
have to look at it honestly.
Yeah. They said something similar to us in
South Africa about that, that, that the,
the, they need the funds
because of the anti poachers,
you know, they, they, they're,
they're all over the place.
And then here's the other problem.
When you say poachers,
these poachers,
you know what you're really saying poor
people. That's what you're really saying.
They're poor,
desperate people.
They don't know what the fuck to do and
if they could chop off a rhino's horn
and make some money,
they're going to do it.
If they can shoot that animal
that's not theirs and use it for me,
they're going to do it. They're starving
to death. I mean they have no options.
There's a pitch people in parts of
Africa that are living in grass huts.
My Buddy Justin wren,
he goes and makes wells for these people
in the Congo and the stories he tells
you would just make your eyes tear up
these the human beings and they're living
like this 24 hours a day for their entire
life. And this is, this is the norm.
So we're talking about poachers will be
talking about people that are fucking
desperate. Yeah, you
can call them poachers.
You could dehumanize them with that term,
but they're just poor people and
the only way, or none of them,
the movie stereotype poachers
somehow to be a couple, some of them,
but most of them aren't.
Now here's what's even crazier.
Most of the anti poaching agents used to
be poachers cause it's nothing else for
them to do. Yeah. That's not surprising.
Now they're poachers again
cause but they're hunting
people that got out of jail
that got out of this position that can't
be anti poaching memorial. They can now.
They just now they, I come
poachers again. Perfect.
This happens to a lot of it's gone well.
When Cam Haines was explaining this to
me and when does he explain it to me?
I'm like,
well course.
So they don't even know how many animals
were left in these areas where people
who have abandoned them, ranches
that were once thriving ways to see.
The thing is most of these animals,
a good percentage of it,
we're on the verge of extinction just 30
years ago because people were just over
hunting them and coaching them and
doing whatever they want it to them.
Then they started putting value on them.
People would go over there to hunt them,
so people would keep these huge areas
in that populations boomed because they
were taking care of them
because they were, they were
a resource, and this is key.
This is conflicting to people.
It's wild. It's very wild.